former et accompagner des personnes en
difficulté ou éloigné du marché du
travail c'est l'ambition de
l'association envie et c'est d'ailleurs
grâce à cette initiative qu'envit Trapp
est devenu un acteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire pour en parler je
suis aujourd'hui avec Éric gastino vous
êtes directeur d'envie bonjour bonjour
alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter l'association
envie oui donc l'association enville
c'est une entreprise
d'insertion qui a pour spécialité la
réparation et la rénovation d'équipement
électroménager son activité économique
elle sert de
support à l'emploi la formation et
l'accompagnement vers le retour à
l'emploi durable de personnes qui
étaient au chômage depuis longtemps donc
comme je disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
acteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donc quelles sont les
initiatives que vous mettez en place
justement pour être dans cette démarche
le social et solidaire ça se traduit par
ça en fait hein c'est que on va inclure
he dans le monde professionnel des gens
qui étaient é en rupture avec le monde
du travail donc il y a cette cette
notion de d'accompagnement et de
solidarité euh j'ai envie on pense que
la valeur le travail dans toutes ces
dimensions collectives dans le contenu
de des formations dans le contenu
intellectuel et et et manuel du métier
va permettre à des gens de se
reconstruire de reprendre confiance euh
de réintégrer aussi un un collectif un
groupe de travail pour ensuite être armé
lorsqu'ils vont sortir d'ici pour
travailler dans nimp quelle entreprise
et concrètement vous avez des exemples
comment vous vlez forz les accompagner
ici alors ici on va les former au
métiers qu'on pratique euh donc c'est la
réparation d'appareils électroménager
mais c'est également des métiers
logistiques ça peut être de la
logistique et la manutention en entrepôt
dans ce cas-là on va leur faire passer
des cassesses par exemple pour apprendre
à conduire des engins de manutention ça
peut être des métier de livraison de
livreur installateur chez nos clients
puisque dans nos prestations on livre et
on installe t nos matériels euh donc sur
ces métiers-là ces métiers-là vont
servir de de support à la
professionnalisation si je peux dire ça
comme ça des personnes qu'on accompagne
euh ceux qui arrivent ici qu'on embauche
pour certains les plus jeunes parfois
n'ont jamais travaillé et donc n'ont pas
la connaissance des codes de
l'entreprise et donc découvrent ce que
c'est que la vie professionnelle et puis
d'autres plus anciens ont eu des
accident de parcours et là on leur remet
le pied à l'écrier et on on leur fait
reprendre confiance dans le travail
aussi he parce que c'est parfois des
gens qui ont été abîmé par le travail
justement donc euh vraiment le le les
métiers que l'on propose ici technique
euh logistique vente également
euh doit donner un bagage
professionnelà une forme technique sous
forme de de de relationnel qui euh
permet d'outiller euh nos salariés pour
les euh ensuite pour qu'il s'envolent
d'ici et qu'il qu'il le voilà qu'il
qu'il fassent preuve de la même
confiance et du même professionnalisme
ailleurs et lorsque leur projet
professionnel s'éloigne de ce que l'on
pratique ici mais on trouve des
solutions pour financer des formations
qui se rapprochent de leur projet si
vous voulez travailler dans les espaces
verts par exemple ben on va essayer de
de trouver des formation de ce type là
pour des personnes qui vont rester
salariées chez nous mais qui vont
parfois faire des périodes d'immersion
dans d'autres entreprises du territoire
et comment vous voulez trouver ces
personnes elles viennent directement à
vous ou comment ça se passe alors on
travaille en relation avec ce qu'on
appelle des prescripteurs sociaux donc
ça peut être po emploi ça peut être les
missions locales pour les plus jeunes ça
peut être d'autres structures de
l'inertion par l'activité
économique voilà on a un certain nombre
de de partenaires autour de nous qui
nous proposent des candidatures ça peut
être aussi des candidatur spontanées et
on
va recruter nos salariés en parcours
d'accompagnement non pas sur une
compétence professionnel hein vous
l'avez bien compris mais sur leur
motivation à s'en sortir et leur
motivation et leur capacité à pouvoir
travailler donc c'est ça qu'on va
évaluer lors d'un ou plusieurs
entretiens et ensuite on va les les
employer dans le cadre de contrat à
durée déterminée d'insertion qui sont
des contrats de 4 mois qu'on peut
renouveler jusqu'à 6 fois pour une
période maximum de 2 ans dans cette
période là de 2 ans tout notre travail
va consister
à définir un projet professionnel pour
les
personnes lever aussi un certain nombre
de freins sociaux périphhériques à pois
ça peut être des problèmes de logement
des problèmes de santé
euh des difficultés comportementales euh
voilà c'est très divers chaque cas est
particulier et et on va travailler en
même temps sur la partie professionnelle
et puis sur l'accompagnement social pour
ça au sein de la structure il y a une
personne entièrement dédiée à cet
accompagnement social et qui va
travailler avec des travailleurs sociaux
du territoire des références sociaux
pour faire progresser et faire
disparaître les difficultés majeures qui
les empêchaient de revenir à l'emploi
donc vous avez un petit peu des chiffres
combien de personnes vous aidez chaque
année ou comment ça se passe alors
chaque année il y a une quarantaine de
personnes qui passent ici il y a un
turnover presque de de 100 % chaque
année la durée moyenne d'un salarié en
parcours chez nous c'est environ 13 mois
et donc souvent parce qu'il partent en
emploi avant la fin des 2 ans puis ceux
qui sont le plus en difficulté on a
tendance à les garder un peu plus
longtemps
euh et donc au final sur l'ensemble de
la structure euh aujourd'hui c'est
environ 25 personnes en équivalent temp
plein sur l'ensemble de l'année qu'on va
accompagner et qu'on va remettre petit à
petit sur le chemin de de l'emploi et
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
combien de personnes ont retrouvé du
travail après ou en tout cas se sont
insérés professionnellement alors oui
c'est c'est un dispositif alors chez
Envie attrape comme dans l'ensemble du
réseau national envie hein puisque envie
c'est un réseau qui réunit une
cinquantaine de structures dans toute la
France
c'est un dispositif qui fonctionne al
moi ma conviction c'est que ça
fonctionne par la par le contenu métier
de ce que l'on pratique ici par la
technicité et et le le professionnalisme
qu'on essaie de mettre en place donc
chaque année c'est environ 80 % des gens
qu'on accueille qui va retrouver soit un
emploi à la sortie sous forme de CDD
long ou de CDI soit une formation
qualifiante de longue durée qui va leur
permettre d'approfondir leurs
connaissances professionnell et depuis
quand vous faites cette démarche vous
avez une date ou pas alors ici
l'activité a démarré en 2012 donc on a
fêté nos 10 ans l'année dernière donc ça
fait un peu plus de 10 ans hein donc
vous faites le calcul c'est c'est plus
de 200 personnes qu'on a remis en emploi
depuis la création de l'association euh
et le réseau enve lui existe depuis 1984
avec une première structure à à
Strasbourg donc ça fait ça fait 40 ans
maintenant pratiquement que le réseau
envie existe que ce dispositif là existe
qui mélange
savoir-faire professionnel et technique
sur ce qu'on appelle l'économie
circulaire donc la le réemploi la la
seconde vie d'appareil
éctroménager et cette activité là qui
sert de support à notre mission sociale
et à à l'inclusion et à la
réintégration de personnes je dirais
dans la société hein c'est à travers le
le monde du travail mais c'est dans la
société de de manière générale donc
c'est un modèle qui fonctionne bien qui
était très innovant qui est toujours et
qui se réinvente
presque chaque jour je dirais bah merci
beaucoup er merci à vous merci alors on
le rappelle en novembre c'est le Mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et pour
cette 16e édition 5 quanttin eneline se
mobilise l'agglomération vous propose
notamment de découvrir et de rencontrer
les acteurs cinquantinois de l' SS grâce
à plusieurs événements vous les
retrouverez dans l'agenda à la fin de
cette émission mais tout de suite je
vous invite à entrer dans l'univers du
Do It Yourself avec t les accessoires